revenu dans ce numéro exceptionnel de
par le manque d'eau en compagnie
d'emmanuel kessler bonjour et manoeuvres
numéro exceptionnel puisque à l'occasion
des 10 ans de la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale et de public sénat
nous recevons sur ce plateau les
présidents des deux assemblées bernard
accoyer président de l'assemblée
nationale bonjour et gérard larcher
président du sénat
messieurs merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau nous sommes ensemble pour 45
minutes alors bernard accoyer vous
occuper le perchoir depuis 2007 et vous
gérard larcher le plateau comme on dit
au sénat depuis 2008 une période marquée
par une intense activité pour le
parlement mais aussi par de nouvelles
règles du jeu dans le fonctionnement de
vos deux assemblées depuis la réforme de
la constitution alors on verra si ça
marche bien on va en parlera largement
en cours de cette émission mais d'abord
on va revenir avec vous sur quelques
temps forts de l'actualité à commencer
bien sûr par le dossier concernant la
future loi sur la burqa aubry démarche
peu commune d'ailleurs vous êtes allé
lundi tous les deux à matignon pour
rencontrer françois fillon et lui dire
que vous étiez opposé à l'utilisation de
la procédure d'urgence pour faire
adopter le futur projet de loi sur le
voile intégral vous dites avoir été
entendu par le premier ministre avant
d'en parler on va revenir sur les
détails avec céline bittner attention
pas de précipitation sur un sujet aussi
sensible que le voile intégral prendre
son temps pour obtenir un véritable
consensus
voilà ce qu'ont plaidé les présidents de
l'assemblée du sénat lors d'une
rencontre avec le premier ministre à
matignon nous fassions notre
tant de journées parlementaires journées
parlementaires adhérant au gouvernement
tous nous voulons prendre le temps de la
réflexion que nous ne voulons pas de
vote imposée de votre confort de
procédure d'urgence il n'est pas
complètement anormal que les deux
présidents d'assemblée répète sur un
rendez vous important ce que nous disons
en permanence à chacune de nos
rencontres la burqa ce n'est pas non
plus l'urgence du moment pour la gauche
et le nouveau centre
on préfère parler retraite des députés
loin d'être d'accord entre sur
l'opportunité au nom d'une loi
d'interdiction du voile intégral si on
veut aboutir à ce que l'assemblée
nationale se rassemblent sur une
question comme celle de la burqa il faut
du temps pour pouvoir travailler et
essayer de bâtir et d'élaborer ce
consensus
et donc on ne comprendrait pas et je ne
comprendrais pas que le gouvernement
essaye de patients quelque sorte en
force mais à droite jean-françois copé
préféré aller vite boucler le dossier
avant l'été un dossier épineux qui
traînent en longueur
le débat dure depuis près d'un an c'est
un sujet sur lequel il faut que nous
avancions faisant le et puis mettons
notre énergie et le travail législatif
au service de loi compliqué la loi sur
la burqa n'est pas une oie compliqué
donc elle peut aller vite donc on peut
déclarer l'urgence alors allez vite ou
laisser le temps de la réflexion
réponse le 19 mai lors de la
présentation du projet de loi sur la
burqa en conseil des ministres en
attendant son sophie on continue de
consulter
alors depuis le premier ministre a
confirmé que le texte serait examiné en
juillet fin juillet début juillet pardon
à l'assemblée en septembre au sénat
il a encore rien dit sur une procédure
d'urgence ou non vous l'avez senti
comment le premier ministre plutôt de
votre côté nous l'avons senti très
attentif
nous lui avons pas dit que nous étions
opposés nous sommes favorables et nous
pensons que la meilleure procédure c'est
une procédure normale pour rechercher le
consensus républicain pour rechercher un
texte applicable pour rechercher un
texte solide jury sensible à vos
arguments
je crois que on est sur un sujet qui est
un sujet important
les valeurs républicaines qu'est ce que
le vivre ensemble cela n'est
naturellement qu'un des éléments et même
s'il ya déjà eu une réflexion à
l'assemblée nationale qui a été conduite
dans le cadre d'une mission nous semble
important que ce texte prenne le temps
du débat républicain approfondie est ce
que les français vous savez ils
souhaitent que leurs parlements
parlemente c'est à dire qu'il se donne
le temps de la réflexion du partage et
de la construction
et c'est aussi l'intérêt du bicamérisme
donc sa voix la voix la procédure quelle
est la procédure normale prévu par la
constitution des alerterait aux
illusions de la république a voulu
renforcer les droits du parlement
ji so n et vous avez aussi un droit de
veto sur la moi c'est dire sur joël est
ce que vous seriez prêt à le faire jouer
c'est à dire ça c'est la constitution
maintenant si je laisse le candidat que
ce serait lui le premier à voir avec les
conférences des présidents donc il faut
que la majorité de la conférence chacune
des assemblées se bat corps et que vous
en pensez moi je pense nous n'y
arriverons pas là le premier ministre
s'est montré très attentif il n'a pas
dit ce qu'il ferait parce que il le dira
le 19 mai le jour de l'examen au conseil
des ministres lu du projet du nord si
les constitutionnel a encore tout à fait
nous nous sommes confiants nous avons
constaté et nous pensons que c'est la
bonne procédure d'aller à fond avec une
certaine sérénité ça ira vite mais sans
précipitation
ça ira vous verrez aussi vite que si on
faisait une procédure d'urgence
un échec de la commission mixte
paritaire et une nouvelle navette après
n'en doutons pas après le texte à
l'assemblée nationale le sénat apportera
sa propre impression et bien sûr sur le
texte parce que c'est aussi le rôle
traditionnellement la chambre haute est
attachée aux valeurs républicaines comme
les députés celui qui met à la liberté
individuelle et collective et
naturellement les lectures dans nos deux
chambres sont nécessaires après ces deux
premières lectures dans chacune de nous
a semblé c'est le fonctionnement normal
de nos institutions
alors que jean françois copé a dit et
redit qu'il était un farouche partisan
d'une procédure d'urgence qu'on légifère
très vite il ya donc deux messages
est-ce que ça brouille pas un petit peu
le message ou tout ça dès que c'est vrai
que la procédure
mais encore une fois nous sommes cas
pour ma part j'ai beaucoup parlé avec
gérard larcher nous pensons que ça n'ira
pas plus vite parce que il n'y aura pas
de consensus entre les deux assemblées
après une première lecture il y aura
donc un échec de la cmp est donc une
nouvelle navette à l'automne donc autant
faire les choses dans la sérénité éviter
que certains se bloque parce qu'on veut
le fait le patron des députés ump est
une voix discordante dans ce set
unanimité vous présenter tous les deux
est ce que ça vous pose problème non non
si je crois que ce pluralisme et qui
enrichit la main jean françois copé mais
pas du tout ah bon j'ai d'excellents
rapports personnels abiquo avec jean
françois copé nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur tout nous l'assumons et
nous apportons chacun notre contribution
vous avez diffusé mois quand même petite
indiscrétion du point vous auriez dit il
déconne à plein tube les indiscrétions
il faut y attacher le crédit qu'elle a
également énormément quand même nom en
tout cas je ne pouvais pas le souvenir
d'avoir dénoncé cette cette phrase comme
envoyer le cavalier seul de jean
françois copé aujourd'hui écoutés et moi
je vais je constate d'abord que au sénat
gérard longuet mais aussi ce serait le
cas du président à bout une autre
président nous souhaitons la procédure
qui donne le temps le temps du débat et
qu'il fasse pas de l'enjeu de la
commission mixte paritaire
un risque d'échec sur un texte aussi
important il nous faut rassembler le
compte des choses c'est que jean
françois copé et à l'intérieur de la
majorité un des présidents groupe qu'à
ce titre là il apporte son dynamisme sa
force sa capacité aussi de persuasion
mais qu' il y a aussi des bas et il est
important que nos concitoyens sachent
que ça fonctionne pas comme ça qu'il y à
débat entre nous et que ce débat il est
légitime
moi je vis le débat mais ceux qui me
connaissent bien au sénat toujours comme
une chance
arm est sûre vous propose d'avancer un
petit peu dans l'actualité de la semaine
en ce mercredi et aussi les dc
l'audition d'edouard balladur par la
mission d'information parlementaire sur
l'attentât de karachi en 2002 audition
qui a duré une heure à huis clos sans
aucune déclaration à la sortie
l'ancien premier ministre avait lui-même
demandé à être entendu après les
articles de libération le mettant en
cause dans la sphère de
rétro-commissions occultes lors de la
vente de sous marins français
au pakistan ban a accueilli on a
l'impression quand même d'une audition
furtive les journalistes n'avaient pas
été prévenus de façon générale on a un
peu l'impression depuis le début des
travaux de la commission qu'on a du mal
à avoir des informations
pourquoi si peu de communication de moi
je suis profondément choquée que sans
arrêt il y ait des suspicions la
campagne de 95
si je compte bien ça fait 15 ans il y a
quinze ans le conseil constitutionnel a
validé les comptes de campagne de la
campagne présidentielle d'edouard
balladur
on remet en cause la validation du john
d'une juillet que jospin on remet en
cause encore une fois la validité et la
validation
bon il n'y a plus de limites c'est sur
sa demande qui doit balladur a voulu
dissiper tous les doutes
il a changé d'avis parce qu'au départ il
souhaitait pas être entendu par la case
en tout cas il a souhaité être entendu
et je crois savoir puisque certains ont
parlé à la sortie qu'il a apporté des
réponses toutes les questions qui ont
été posées
arrêtons sans arrêt de remettre et de se
reposer des questions et même des gîtes
de deux formulé des accusations et les
suspicions m apparaît suffisamment
important pour qu'une mission
d'information et elle a su et elle est
en cours il ya pas besoin de secret
défense aussi de transparence depuis
tous les cas je m'aperçois que
l'assemblée nationale comme aujourd'hui
au sénat sur xynthia un autre sujet
important
il ya des missions d'information les le
parlement exerce son pouvoir tout non
droite il faut qu'ils aient la presse
pour le titiller un peu pour le pousser
un peu parlé non cette mission n'a été
déclenchée à l'initiative des
parlementaires et donc je ne sais pas ce
qui s'est passé l'été à cette mission
lappartient l'assemblée nationale mais
en tous les cas vous voyez l'exercice du
pouvoir de contrôle et je crois que nos
concitoyens sont attentifs à ce que nous
exercions pouvoir de contrôle autre
actualité sensible cette semaine le
risque de faillite de la grèce le
parlement va devoir voter pour débloquer
à près de 4 milliards d'euros pour
athènes dans le cadre de l'aide
européenne qui doit se mettre en place
alors vous le voyez sur ces images
françois baron a été entendu par la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale ce mr
dit le ministre du budget sera aussi
auditionné par celle du sénat le 4 mai
gérard larcher on voit monter
l'inquiétude face à ge à la dette d'un
certain nombre de pays européens plus
seulement la grèce aujourd'hui est ce
que ça ne risque pas de nous arriver
pour nous aussi
alors tout d'abord sur ce dossier je
dois dire que je mène un certain nombre
de consultations
là l'histoire je recevais le président
accoyer l'a reçu c'était d'ailleurs son
invitation mais je j'ai reçu le
président du parlement portugais
je viens recevoir ce matin le président
du sénat des pays-bas ancien président
du conseil de l'europe est naturellement
le sujet ça n'a pas été simplement la
grèce met l'euro la paire il pour l'euro
non je ne pense pas que nous en sommes à
cette situation
simplement c'est l'occasion de dire
qu'est ce qui est essentiel à la
construction européenne et à expliquer à
nos concitoyens
or l'euro c'est un des piliers de la
réalité européenne aujourd'hui tout
comme la politique agricole commune
ça veut dire qu'il faut voter cette aide
à la grèce et le service est
naturellement tout ce qui pourrait
affaiblir l'euro affaiblir la cohésion
de l'europe et donc je le dis clairement
il nous faut soutenir la grèce avec des
exigences et sans doute réfléchir
pourquoi nous n'avons pas été assez
exigeant la mise en place des procédures
cécile ans d'exil est ce parce que c'est
la première fois que nous rencontrons ce
genre de difficulté à l'intérieur de la
semaine et comme nous nous sommes
adaptés la crise financière et il y aura
le 10 mai une réunion des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement sur ce sujet
personnellement la semaine prochaine je
serai en alarme ce parcours du goût
d'une strate élu président des strates
et du bundestag et naturellement ce
sujet il est un sujet moins cher à leurs
portes à l'europe aux allemands qu'ils
aient retardé les choses on est très en
retard que c'est pas une question
particulière entre l'allemagne la france
la grèce je ne sais quel autre pays il
ya eu une crise et il y à une crise
entre n'est pas tout à fait encore sorti
d'une gravité extraordinaire et la
situation financière grecque
la crise de l'euro n'est pas déconnectée
de cela et vous poser la question pour y
avoir des problèmes en france d'abord il
ya d'autres pays qui pourraient
concerner bien avant mais il faut
évidemment se poser la question pour la
france
et comme le disait tout l'art gérard
larcher en écoutant le président du
parlement portugais
je les entends dû m'expliquer alors que
la monnaie l'euro et pendant le portugal
est attaqué et qu'il sut finances
difficilement les réformes qui ont été
conduites par la gauche au portugal à
titre d'exemple concernant les retraites
on porter l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans
et un seul fonctionnaire sur trois
partant à la retraite est remplacé dans
la fonction publique d'état et dans les
fonctions publiques locales
c'est vous dire l'importance et
l'urgence des réformes que nous devons
conduire et les français ne peuvent pas
s'exonérer de ses réformes
sinon il en va et fait une demande de
notre avenir et la valeur et la valeur
de des fonds
on emprunte le taux d'intérêt les pays
doivent payer pour se financer dans la
zone euro c'est décisif de toute notre
marge de manoeuvre c'est à dire de notre
avenir en ce qui concerne le niveau de
vie le budget de l'aide financière
française est ce que est ce que la grèce
sera en mesure de rembourser 7 cas
d'abord resteront au niveau du parlement
je crois savoir que nous irons peut-être
un consensus pour cette fois finances
rectificatif je m'en féliciterais ce
serait une solidarité exemplaire quand
quittera la cinquantaine au sénat pour
sa soumission quant à la capacité de
remboursement de la grèce ce qui
m'ennuie ce qui me préoccupe beaucoup
c'est que le refinancement de la grèce
est devenue un produit spéculatif est
donc là il ya effectivement des
inquiétudes à ce consensus haussier au
sénat vous espérez le vote de la russie
par exemple d'un gouvernement et d'une
gouvernance économique européenne
je crois que c'est l'occasion sûr de le
réaffirmer de manière extrêmement forte
nous voyons qu'il y à là la nécessité et
qu'il va falloir y apporter des réponses
second sujet insistant sûr parce que
traditionnellement je crois que il y
aura en tous les cas un assez large
accord parce que chacun sait que l'euro
est un des soubassements la réalité
européenne d'aujourd'hui et que ça passe
par une solidarité avec des exigences
vis-à-vis de la grèce mais aussi
exigence pour tous les pays de l'union
européenne de la zone euro il ya des
réalités aujourd'hui auquel que nous
devons regarder en face expliqué nos
concitoyens que même si nous étions des
égoïstes que le coût économique
financier social d'un abandon de la
grèce serait beaucoup plus lourd que le
soutien que nous allons apporter
on va passer maintenant messieurs si
vous le voulez bien à une question qui
vous concerne tous les deux au premier
chef les français aiment t-il leur
parlement la réponse dans un sondage
exclusif
et tout de suite donc les résultats du
sondage que nous avons effectués pour
cette émission spéciale de parlement
hebdo les institutions que vous présidez
ont-elles la cote l'institut csa
interrogées les français est bien la
question avez vous une bonne opinion du
parlement dans son ensemble c'est à dire
de l'assemblée du sénat bonnes opinions
42% mauvaise 48 vous le voyez 10% ne se
prononcent pas sur cette question vous
allez le voir d'ailleurs les clivages
politiques sont tout de même assez
marquées entre sympathisants de droite
et sympathisants de gauche on devrait le
voir voilà sur ce panneau je voulais
voir les chiffres c'est assez assez
nette et puis il ya une autre question
audio est ce sondage selon vous
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
contrôle est il suffisamment l'action du
président de la république est bien 26 %
seulement des français et pour nous et
59 % quand même estime que ce contrôle
n'est pas suffisant pour dire que la
même question avait été posée en 2008
avec pratiquement le même résultat
alors un certain scepticisme des
réserves est ce que vous n'êtes pas un
peu déçu par
si la première on l'a bien vu dans le
sondage il y a un caractère partisan
dans le jugement porté sur le parlement
c'est normal la majorité est à droite
les français qui se sentent des
convictions de gauche sont plus sévères
mais gili a depuis toujours en france
depuis qu'il ya des parlementaires il ya
eu de l'antiparlementarisme la crise qui
crée la détresse ne peut qu'aggraver ce
sentiment il nous revient de faire des
efforts pour montrer créé en réalité
nous travaillons beaucoup que nous nous
avons notamment dans le domaine du
contrôle puisque c'est aussi un point
qui est mis en exergue par exemple ici
produit 170 rapport en un petit peu plus
d'un an
alors nous avons une responsabilité
c'est que nous ne le faisons pas assez
savoir et bien à nous aussi faire des
efforts pour mieux faire connaître
l'importance du travail des
parlementaires le rôle qui est le nôtre
en réalité vous savez que j'ai été élu
il ya 18 mois je m'étais donné à défi
c'est qu'on puisse répondre à une
question lancinante des français
préfèrent le cdh a depuis 18 mois
je crois que dans le cas du bicamérisme
c'est aussi un travail que nous
connaissions avec le président de
l'assemblée nationale
nous essayons texte à prétexte de
démontrer à quoi sert le bicamérisme et
notamment à côté de l'assemblée
nationale une chambre comme le sénat en
regardant puisque j'ai eu le bonheur des
téléspectateurs n'ont pas eue d'avoir
l'analyse on s'aperçoit que oui affiné
plus de jeunes une majorité de jeunes
font confiance au parlement ce qui est
prometteur mais qui est pour nous une
exigence une exigence et notamment dans
la fonction de contrôle mais aussi par
rapport à la réflexion sur la société
nouvelle qui est la nôtre parce que la
société d'aujourd'hui et demain c'est
pas la société d'hier
c'est la société qu'il faut construire
pour les jeunes voilà pourquoi je
reviens des débats de société
il faut aussi que le parlement de temps
en temps prenne son temps alors pour
compléter ce sondage on a voulu prendre
quelques avis dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée du sénat
on s'est glissée dans des groupes qui
viennent visiter l'assemblée et le sénat
on aura demandé ce qu'il pensait de
l'heure
ne pas le monde parlementaire pardo
voici le résultat c'est un sujet de
jérôme rabier et hélène mangeard dit je
crois pas que les citoyens s'intéressent
beaucoup à ce système de fonctionnement
parce que le mans ils ont l'impression
que c'est loin à paris quand vous
habitez marseille ou bordeaux
c'est loin vous savez quel est le rôle
des sénateurs oui ils votent les lois et
c'est important pour autoriser le
gouvernement met superbement que au
départ nous a expliqué un petit peu le
rôle du député ce qu'il faisait dans le
connaissez mais peut-être nombre vous
connaissez la différence entre le sénat
et l'assemblée nationale
non pas du tout c'est le coeur c'est
coeur de la démocratie quoi est ce que
vous connaissez les sénateurs de votre
département
je connais un oui je les connais une
question comme on
donc voila mais j'ai j'avoue c'est faut
vraiment que je réfléchisse j'aimerais
devenir et voir davantage de députés
dans l'hémicycle
voilà moi ce que ce que j'aimerais bien
aussi ce que le président de l'assemblée
limite le cumul des mandats ça c'est
peut-être un voeu pieux j'aimerais
savoir quelle est la différence entre
les députés et sénateurs parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est un peu la même
chose ils votent les lois tous les deux
mais j'aimerais bien savoir la
différence entre les sénateurs et
députés
malgré tout les jeunes ne sont quand
même pas totalement au courant même si
même s'ils ont perdu tous leurs
parlements on va garder cette dernière
question si vous deviez bien parce qu'on
n'a pas le temps de toutes les faire
c'est quoi en deux mots la différence
entre un député et un sénateur gérard
larcher tout d'abord le mode électoral
oui sommes élus au suffrage universel
indirect
mais la grande différence c'est que nous
ne procédons pas depuis la réforme du
quinquennat de l'élection présidentielle
les députés sont élus à la suite de
l'élection présidentielle et des quatre
grandes institutions
trois procès de l'élection
présidentielle la présidence le
gouvernement l'assemblée nationale le
sénat élu par les représentants des
collectivités territoriales obéit à un
autre rite qui d'ailleurs lui donne une
fonction différente mais une réalité
différente ce qui d'ailleurs donne une
part d'autonomie un peu spécifique au
sénat oui il ya une passe du bicamérisme
une assemblée qui ont arrosé un
bicamérisme est absolument fondamental
pour faire de benoît contraint
d'assembler les nains les meilleures
possibles mais ce n'est pas l'élément
les balades les députés sont en prise
directe avec leurs électeurs scrutin
uninominal direct à deux tours
donc nous joue le rôle de courroie de
transmission entre le terrain et la
majorité et de cette majorité est issue
le gouvernement et ce rôle il est très
direct
ça fait qu'il y ait des réactions
parfois plus vivent ici à l'assemblée
qu'au sénat dont le mode électoral plus
longtemps et plus protégés
un petit peu plus de recul ou de hauteur
pour eux pour être tout à fait côté
charmant mais nous mais nous nous sommes
vraiment pris je dirais que donc il faut
réagir très vite parfois un peu fort je
reconnais volontiers la course
transmission devient défaut parfois du
poil à gratter pour le gouvernement
oui mais c'est une bonne chose le poil à
gratter jamais nous on est parfois un
peu démultiplier ce qui donne en
mécanique de force
on va maintenant aborder les grands
dossiers de la session parlementaire en
cours le point sur quelques questions
chaudes réforme des collectivités
locales taxe professionnelle bouclier
fiscal comment le parlement at-il
imprimer sa marque au cours des derniers
mois delphine girard octobre 2009 début
de la discussion budgétaire à
l'assemblée nationale les députés ump
aux côtés de l'opposition remettent en
cause des dispositions majeures du texte
il propose même un assouplissement du
bouclier fiscal en faisant sortir la
crds de son calcul s'appelle taurine
yacht essaie simplement de constater
qu'une fois que la dette sociale est là
elle est faite les boîtes de médicaments
ont été achetés les retraites ont été
payés il ya une dette à rembourser mais
à partir de ce moment là c'est pas tout
à fait un impôt la crds et ça nous
semble équitable que tout le monde
participe aux commandes de ce
remboursement
la fronde contre le bouclier fiscal
atteindra son paroxysme au printemps
2010 ce ne sont pas les revenus du
travail qui sont protégés par le
bouclier fiscal mais bien les revenus et
patrimoines au sénat c'est la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
qui met le feu aux poudres novembre 2009
jean pierre raffarin une vingtaine de
sénateurs ump menacent de ne pas voter
le budget en l'état nous sommes d'accord
avec le gouvernement en ce qui concerne
les entreprises plus de taxe
professionnelle au 1er janvier 2010 mais
nous disons que la réforme du côté des
collectivités locales elle ne doit
s'appliquer qu'au 1er janvier 2011 entre
temps nous souhaitons pouvoir évaluer le
système faire des simulations reçu par
christine lagarde
les sénateurs obtiendront du
gouvernement des garanties en matière de
remboursement de la taxe professionnelle
principale source de revenus des
collectivités territoriales car en cette
fin d'année 2009 pas question de toucher
aux collectivités territoriales leur
réforme fera l'objet de vives
discussions au sein de la haute
assemblée
votons supprimer les départements qu'on
le dise
votons affaiblir les régions qu'on la
firme sans cesse on est entre le flou le
vague l'imprécis qui laisse penser qu'il
y à un certain nombre de dessins qui
sont cachés des desseins cachés des
menaces sur les collectivités locales
dans ses réformes ou dit le sénateur
jean pierre sueur et une brève hyper
sensibilité là dessus vous les sur russe
a d'ailleurs été le sujet de l'année au
sénat de l'année dernière il ya eu la
mission belot le sénat considérablement
travailler ce dossier mais je voudrais
revenir sur la taxe professionnelle car
c'est l'exemple même du travail entre
eux l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
au moins l'examen du budget le
rapporteur général du budget gilles
carez s'engage pourquoi parce que nous
avions conjointement obtenu les
présidents de groupes politiques de la
majorité les présidents des deux
assemblées à ce que le gouvernement
confie à nos deux assemblées la
responsabilité de faire la
transformation concrètes et la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle
c'est un travail qui a été conduit par
nos deux assemblées par nos commissions
des finances et nous avons pu obtenir la
réforme nécessaire pour la compétitivité
de nos entreprises
j'avais la réalité de la crise c'est
qu'il faut aussi qu'on s'adapte à la
compétitivité globale d'un monde ouvert
et que nous adaptons notre industrie
c'est la suppression d'impôt takeri en
même temps assurer les ressources aux
collectivités territoriales donc une
année 2010
qui est une année qu'on va appeler
neutre pour ses collections qu'avec le
par les uns étaient entendus clause de
revoyure et nous avons construit
ensemble n'ont d'ailleurs une navette
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
les conditions de la réforme de la taxe
a de grands dossiers de bataille aussi
bernard acoyer ça a été le bouclier
fiscal ya même des députés oui parce que
je veux dire deux mots sur la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
voilà plus de trente ans que cet impôt
affaiblit la compétitivité des
entreprises françaises
détruit par conséquent de l'emploi
l'essentiel le courage du gouvernement
et de la majorité aura été de supprimer
la taxe professionnelle pour les
entreprises industrielles voyez je suis
un élu de terrain je suis ce que font
les entreprises dans mon département la
haute savoie une grande entreprise du
bassin annécien la suppression de la
taxe professionnelle c'est tout de suite
2 millions d'euros que fait-elle cette
entreprise fait l'investît et elle va
construire des grandes banques à des
roulements à billes géant pour les
éoliennes que l'on apportera la crème et
une grande inquiétude des collectivités
locales qu'ils veulent a priori l'a
priori la priorité c'est l'emploi
parce que pour nourrir même les noms et
les vallées pour nourrir les
collectivités locales
il faut qu'il y ait des entreprises qui
créent des richesses pour donner des
salaires et du pouvoir d'achat aux
français
il faut des entreprises qui créent des
richesses c'est bien là une des actions
emblématiques et majeures de ce
gouvernement de cette majorité
personne n'avait osé le faire avant sur
le bouclier fiscal
je voudrais rappeler que c'est une des
mesures d'une loi que la l'opposition a
vilipendé qui s'appelle travail emploi
pouvoir d'achat
revenons sur ce texte à peu près 5 % de
son coût correspond au bouclier fiscal
afin qu'il reste en france des
investisseurs privés parce que le défaut
d'investissement privé est un des
principaux problèmes de la france qui
n'investit plus assez dans son appareil
industriel pour créer des emplois
dans le même temps dit que c'est même
temps on attend le maine attendant
même temps 95% 95% des successions en
france sont désormais exonérés d'impôts
exonérés de droits de succession et dans
le même temps les heures supplémentaires
ont été déchargés sur plan fiscal et ce
plan des charges sociales voilà la
réalité et chacun reconnaît que cela a
contribué grandement à faire qu'en
france on semblait moins mal tiré après
la crise ou durant la crise que les
autres pays et je pourrais ajouter la
tva à 5,5 dans la restauration c'est
cinquante mille emplois sauvés dans mon
département la haute savoie j'ai
d'innombrables témoignages douteux liés
de petits restaurateurs qui m'ont dit eh
ben on a été sauvé par sa roue on a pu
embaucher alors on a peu de temps pour
aborder une question sensible la réforme
des retraites mais on sait que c'est une
question sur laquelle les français
attendent beaucoup de justice mais sont
très précises puisque vous êtes les
premiers concernés
est ce que vous êtes favorable à ce
qu'on révise pour qu'ils aient la
justice appliquée tout le monde le
régime de retraite des parlementaires
dont on dit qu'il est très favorable
d'abord parlons des retraites et on
abordera la question des retraites des
parlementaires si vous le voulez dire de
niedner viande dans le parlement sommes
d'abord responsable de la partie
législative de la réforme des retraites
moi je suis très sensible à la volonté
d'équité mais aussi il faut qu'on dise
les yeux dans les yeux français pour
qu'on évite la situation de la grèce où
un moment pendant 30 ans dean pas la
réalité aux grecs
et voilà le résultat nous avons la
nécessité de reconnaître que
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
nous avons l'obligation de prendre en
compte la nécessité
j'ai des ministres en charge du travail
et je connais particulièrement bien ce
sujet du nombre d'années de cotisations
nous devons prendre en compte aussi la
pénibilité le camp la convergence
progressive des systèmes et
naturellement ce qui concerne les
parlementaires ils participeront de la
convergence des systèmes
c'est bien de là dessus et d'ailleurs au
sénat qui a un système un peu différents
de l'asssemblée nationale même si les
montants sur les mêmes nous avons
augmenté de près de 8 30 la cotisation
des sénateurs et le personnel du sénat a
lui même accepté la proposition que le
bureau lui faisait d'augmenter dont sa
cotisation rendre hollande année
ensemble les députés aussi si accoyer
oui bien entendu les députés feront le
même effort que celui qui sera devant du
cancer à la viande concert solide nous
l'avions déjà fait ou n'a pas attendu
cette réforme pour réduire un certain
nombre de dispositifs adaptés à certains
noms dispositif et vous continuez c'est
le mets mais vous me permettrez de
revenir encore une autre sens d'ailleurs
je rêvais déjà uni j'aimerais revenir
également sur la question des retraites
c'était un des dossiers essentiels je
voudrais donner quelques chiffres six
ans 80 de la gauche n'avait pas abaissé
l'âge de la retraite de 65 à 60 ans le
régime général la caisse générale de
vieillesse sécurité sociale serait
aujourd'hui excédentaire si le
gouvernement balladur n'avait pas fait
la réforme de 93 les déficits seraient
infiniment plus importants et si au
début de cette législature et pensions
la réforme la réforme des régimes
spéciaux n'avait pas été fait ce serait
la même chose donc c'est toujours la
majorité de la droite et du centre qui à
opérer les réformes qui ont sauvé les
rings du repas que nous allons continuer
mais pour être plus précis sur le
système de pension vieillesse des
députés qui auraient vite et date de
1904 pour faire que il n'ya pas que des
fonctionnaires qu'ils puissent devenir
parlementaire
encore une fois nous adapterons notre
dispositif de telle façon que l'effort
qui sera un fait ici soit le même que
celui censuré augmentation des
cotisations
il y aura sûrement s'il y aura ou y aura
plusieurs il y aura plusieurs variables
comme probablement ce qui sera issu du
travail parlementaire
si l'exemple par une autre système
spécifique nous avons déjà augmenté de
cotisation et nous aurons un rendez vous
dans le cadre de l'audit triennal en
deux ans et demi
en plus de cette convergence que nous
nous appliquerons naturellement parce
que nous sommes aussi les français comme
les journées seront l'occasion bien sûr
9 par elle et alors on va maintenant
aborder la question de la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 elle devait
renforcer a le rôle du parlement donner
plus de pouvoir à l'opposition
eh bien on va voir le bilan près de deux
ans plus tard alors cette révision at
elle été un plus pour l'opposition
d'abord à l'assemblée nationale la
réforme amis par exemple en place dès
journée d'initiative parlementaire pour
l'opposition encore le droit de créer
une commission d'enquêté par session
dans la pratique tout cela ne marche pas
comme ces députés de l'opposition le
souhaiterait bilan mitigé dressé par
jean baptiste daoulas l'opposition sorte
elle vraiment gagnante de la réforme
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008
l'avancée la plus incontestable c'est
l'attribution de la présidence de la
commission des finances à l'opposition
une fonction attribué en 2007 à didier
migaud remplacé cette année par un autre
socialiste jérôme cahuzac
les finances ou comment mieux contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
un meilleur contrôle qui aurait aussi dû
prendre la forme de commission denquête
la réforme prévoyait que chaque groupe
pouvez en créer une
chaque année pas si simple ainsi en
novembre 2009
les socialistes veulent d'enquêté sur
les sondages commandés par l'elysée la
commission des lois repoussent leurs
demandes dans une ambiance houleuse
quelques semaines plus tard
nouveau refus cette fois pour les
députés communistes qui souhaitaient
enquêter sur les suicides à france
télécom désormais l'opposition disposent
tous les mois d'une journée pour
défendre ses propositions de loi est un
nazi droit de vote des étrangers ou
encore adoption par les couples pacsés
des propositions défendues par la gauche
depuis septembre mais chaque fois le
rituel est le même lot
ici on s'exprime dans un hémicycle
déserté par la droite le gouvernement
utilise la procédure du vote bloqué et
les députés ump ne viennent que la
semaine suivante pour repousser le texte
en bloc
en novembre dernier lors de l'examen du
texte sur l'euthanasie les socialistes
quittent l'hémicycle le gouvernement
méprisent l'opposition est aujourd'hui
c'est une véritable humiliation à
laquelle nous assistons une opposition
peu satisfaite de la nouvelle règle du
jeu à l'assemblée elle réclame déjà des
ajustements alors les hémicycle déserté
par la majorité je vous cite quand même
le socialiste jacques urvoas qui dit les
studios des médias sont devenus les
seuls à rennes utile de la démocratie
comment peut-on éviter cet absentéisme
des députés est d'abord est ce que vous
êtes ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce
que vous constatez cet absentéisme
je pense que sur l'absentéisme avons
beaucoup progressé c'est à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup d'absents et vous pourriez
ainsi les cités et citer la présence
effective en commission qui est
désormais sanctionner financièrement
lorsqu'elle est défaillante c'était une
mesure qui est concrètement appliquée et
également la présence lors des scrutins
publics qui est sanctionné s'il y a une
absence excessives par rapport aux
règlements et c'est la première fois
qu'on applique ces deux articles du
règlement
maintenant vous êtes venus sur les
droits de l'opposition je ne peux pas
laisser dire que les droits de
l'opposition n'auraient pas été amélioré
et grandement améliorée par ce très fort
il y à l'égalité du temps d'intervention
dans toutes les activités ou
d'évaluation et contrôle il y a dans les
commissions d enquête comme vous l'avez
dit elle rapporterait un cours à porter
qui sont qui sont de la majorité l'autre
de l'opposition
il ya toujours cet équilibre notamment
au centre d'une nouvelle instance qui
est le comité d'évaluation et de
contrôle qui est en train d'investiguer
un certain nombre de domaines il y à 60%
du temps dans les groupes réservé à
l'opposition de temps de parole des
groupes réservé à l'opposition et 40% à
la majorité il y a cela a été souligné
le président de la seule commission qui
a un droit d'investigation sur pièces et
sur place un droit d'en quête sur pièces
et sur place qui a été octroyé et c'est
dans notre règlement à un député de
l'aube
vision je ne peux pas dire je ne peux
pas laisser dire qu'il n'y a pas
davantage de droits
quant à ce qui a été souligné c'est à
dire le fait qu'il n'y aurait pas une
majorité fait de députés de la majorité
lors des discussions des propositions de
loi issues de l'opposition dans aucun
parlement au monde je dis bien dans
aucun par le manteau monde et il n'y à
l'opposition qui fait la loi
alors il y à des dispositions qui font
qu'on peut voir mais il est bien l'un
des bars de pigalle débat il ya le débat
mais ces jours là effectivement
rappelons qu elle niche ont été
multipliés par trois le nombre des
propositions issues de l'opposition qui
était multiplié par 3 c'est un droit
supplémentaire dénonce position c'est la
messe et le vote le vote le vote bloqué
le vote solennel je sais pas chaude et
l'on sait quelque chose
les premiers la chaussée qui donne par
exemple prenez l'exemple de la fane vie
admettez que le jeudi on vote
l'assemblée vote pour l'euthanasie il y
à des familles à des personnes qui
souffrent qui attendent quelque chose en
ce domaine le jeudi on vote raient cela
et puis on au scrutin solennel le mardi
suivant votre aile contraire non nous
sommes obligés d'avoir une certaine
responsabilité dans la continuité de nos
votes de nos décisions à mai en résumé
c'est trois fois plus de niches qu'avant
la réforme
alors il ya un aspect un peu
complémentaire je voudrais qu'on voit
tout de suite avec le témoignage
l'interpellation d'un de vos collègues
sénateurs socialistes jean-pierre michel
sur le fait qu si on s'attendait que
cette cette réforme simplifie le travail
parlementaire on en fait beaucoup plus
en commission et en réalité on a sans
doute redoublé aussi les choses en
séance alors qu'on s'attendait à ce que
les discussions soit un peu plus rapide
parce que justement maintenant on
discute davantage un commission écouter
jean pierre michel la fin de cette
session ordinaire a vu appliquer la
nouvelle constitution notamment faits
concernent de travail en commission et
en séance
et on peut dire que selon le succès
résultat les commissions
très longue le ministre venir en
commission
donc il ya un débat en commission qui
est un vrai débat de séance et ça n'a
aucun intérêt
voilà on a redoublé les choses c'est ce
que dit un peu d'amis celle des débats
en commission qui n'aurait aucun intérêt
alors qu'on va au fond des choses en
commission je crois que simplement il
faut qu on s'acclimate à une nouvelle
procédure où c'est en commission qu'on
prépare la loi et c'est naturellement au
cours de la séance que dans un débat qui
reste largement ouvert les amendements à
la loi sont progressivement construit et
on construit la loi je crois que nous
avons encore un temps d'apprentissage du
rôle et de la place de la commission
nouvelle formule avec le rôle et la
place de la séance publique
je crois aussi qu'il nous sommes en
train de le mettre en place il faut une
traçabilité des travaux en commission
puisqu'on y construit la loi
c'est ce que nous mettons en place au
sénat et c'est tout à fait récent avec
la mise en place d'un compte rendu
analytique des débats en commission à
l'assemblée nationale is it et les
avaient précédés sur ce point c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
mais je voudrais dire que le fait de
partager toutes les missions
d'information les commission denquête
présidents et rapporteurs la majorité
l'autre de l'opposition
c'est une formidable avancée des droits
des parlementaires majorité comme
opposition aurait fait que parce qu'ils
ont sur la darse et location nous allons
avoir un texte qui a été adopté ici
violences faites aux femmes qui sera
inscrit au mois de juin consensus serbe
qui va le connaître aussi un travail
parlementaire établissements publics
locaux une proposition socialiste au
sénat de daniel raoul que sans doute
nous allons adopter tout n'est pas si
noir que cela et en même temps des
missions où chacun a sa liberté
regardez la mission xynthia vous croyez
que bruno retailleau et le président
socialiste de la mission sénateur de la
gironde avait tout à fait le même
sentiment que le gouvernement dans les
décisions prises en charente maritime et
en vendée
donc un rôle du parlement qui répond aux
attentes des citoyens
retailleau sénateur vendéen proche de
philippe de villiers juste d'un mot les
socialistes se voit déjà majoritaire au
sénat en 2011 vous le craignez au jeu ne
craint
la démocratie je ne la craint jamais
mais nous sommes à 18 mois vous croyez
que c'est ça qui préoccupent les
français
aujourd'hui les français sont préoccupés
d'abord paru l'emploi savez peut-être
trop marqué par mes fonctions
antérieures
c'est vraiment ça que j'ai entendu y
compris au cours de la campagne
régionale
nous avons arpenté les savoie avec le
président accueillait et c'est vraiment
le sujet et l'emploi sujet de la réforme
des retraites le sujet de l'équité
global
la crise agricole qui est très très
forte et qui va nous amener dans les
semaines qui viennent au sénat puis à
l'assemblée
voilà les sujets et puis le viendra le
moment
il viendra et bien en fonction du vote
des grands électeurs
eh bien les sénateurs voteront ce qui
compte c'est que le sénat remplissent
pendant ces 18 mois pleinement la
mission qui est la sienne
allez pour terminer cette émission va se
détendre un peu si vous le voulez bien
avec 100 débutantes vous êtes des taux
est encore plus nette encore n'auront
plus à être gentil merci il ya de vie
donc des couacs et des flops
à l'assemblée comme au sénat pas de
jaloux ouf alors depuis septembre on
s'en souvient il ya eu l'assaut de
l'assemblée par greenpeace ou encore des
cartons jaunes brandis par des sénateurs
en plein hémicycle des débats houleux
tout cela ce sont des incidents
qu'aucune conférence des présidents
aussi organisées soit elle ne peut
prévoir et qui donne bien sûr des
couleurs à la vie démocratique recueil
de morceaux choisis par yohan arlat
n'y at il pas là sinon conflit d'intérêt
pour le moins confusion des genres je
sais pas ce que vous essayez démontrer
au travers de votre question stupide
mais j'aurais du mal à y répondre
autrement que comme cela
demandé au ministre du budget a exprimé
des excuses et de retirer le mot stupide
ould propagande politique est absolument
inadmissible que les passions chez fond
c'est vrai qu'il a des droits
tout jamais connu mon cher collègue vous
aurez la parole comme vous le
demander monsieur y est vous continuez
les étudiants du
le président vient d'interrompre cette
séance car il semble qu'il y ait à
nouveau de militants 2010
j'ai porté ce matin plainte première
fois
tu
charlie ban d'rôle sûr
toit de l'assemblée nationale nous
allons déposer une seconde plainte pour
cette intrusion et les incidents de cet
après midi monsieur attendu la
présidence
oui après cette annonce banque année
bah reprographie quand vous savez que
personne ne veut de la privatisation de
la poste
il est quand même facile d'interroger
les gens me vouloir conclure
m
voilà vous avez regardé ces images avec
passion faut conclure cette émission
d'un mot chaîne parlementaire en disant
qu est ce que vous leur souhaiter pour
les dix années à venir comme un jour que
cela se passe toujours de mieux en mieux
que la mission soit remplie avec
satisfaction pour ce qu'il assume et
également pour ceux qui la suivent
d'ailleurs leur écran ce set au service
de la démocratie bien mieux faire
connaître les travaux du parlement je
crois que c'est utile démocratie vous
avez relais une place particulière qui
n'est pas simplement une chaîne d'info
mais je crois de partager un certain
nombre de valeurs qui transcende tous
les clivages dans la société et on voit
bien dans les images qu'on a vu que y
compris les pulsions de la société
s'exprime au parlement finalement ça
démontre que la démocratie est vivante
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
rendez-vous sont universels n'oublions
pas ceux qui vous ont créé en fait que
c'est rené monory qu'à une premier lit d
une chaîne parlementaire puis christian
poncelet en ce qui concerne le sénat je
pense aussi à jacques valade à tous ceux
qui ont été les porter jean pierre
elkabbach est aujourd'hui bloqué ici
laurent fabius nationales merci à tous
rendez vous dans dix ans et puis bien
sûr avant un à bien ces routes
merci au revoir prochaine
le 6 mai prochain
les anglais de branche ou